hello and welcome to this video playing
it's why each to me - I don't think it
relates to the me - movement listen it
was one before that was a topic anyway
we have a trump the Trump
you
you
the only thing I remember is that this
is a line but I have forgotten
absolutely everything then after it what
happening what's happening now I just I
have to tell that because it was it was
just so funny okay but what what we're
doing in sis
no no 97 or something
I can actually take and you always have
to be a little bit inert about 19 B 5 D
5 g v5 stuff because yeah blacks
development it's not great that just
develop stuff I just had had a good
laugh because somebody posted a comment
on one of my videos at the end of 2012
this is more than 6 years ago I made a
small video series on how to fight the
London system something that at the time
was not yet a topical opening line
nowadays it is very frequently seen
anyway the comment was really funny ever
failed yet he would like yeah you're a
pompous ass yeah and your analysis is
weak and I no wonder that you have so
few views I just found pompous ass I
really like that I also like that he
felt the analysis was weak
most people honestly don't even
understand what an analysis is how an
analysis looks like most of what I do if
I look at the stuff I wouldn't call
analysis is just a brief look actually
and yeah
who channels
that what is that there are whole
channels that have not a single video
with chess analysis and people
continuously post our great analysis and
there is no analysis they just like play
through the moves and don't don't
actually analyze anything there is no
quest for finding out where let's say
the mistake was and so on therefore you
cannot call it analysis I mean I'm not
really criticizing other channels just
what it is
some of its just like an entertaining
playthrough of the games but it is
definitely not analysis and this is fine
sometimes also only want a quick view
one on the games without yeah some some
precise some precise scientific approach
especially if I don't have much time and
sometimes just want a quick information
like how was the and how was Magnus this
game yesterday that he warned or
whatever and then over breakfast I I
watch a quick video of 15 minutes or
something like what any King does for
example is a good overview that's fine
so not really analysis what he does it's
not very deep and it's just like what I
usually do if I look at a master game or
one of my games it's just a brief
examination what was happening analysis
is what like Robert Hooke notice or
something that is a truly scientific
approach and something that
yeah warrants the the tomb so anyway um
just a small thing I really love the
pompous ass that was funny even if you
insult yeah just do it in some with some
funny funny words not like a you a
stupid you stupid [ __ ] or something
pompous ass is cool let's do that
okay so rook d7 Bishop c6
rooty seven bishops Isaac should be fine
Bishop f3 is mine is the move that I
expect
I came what makes an awful lot of sense
to smooth
well
don't think about that at all that is
embarrassing but I had a good laugh
about the pompous ass Bishop g2 g1 is
bad
[Music]
that is that is a very embarrassing move
to play
maybe it's still not lost
you
probably rookie aid then huh
that could be still could be somewhat
playable it looks bad but
you
what do I wonder what I miss played you
anyway some of this
I just have to get get to get pieces in
players no other way to do it giving up
a pawn is just it's not I'm not happy
about it but it's um I guess unavoidable
I am I really suck in this game
Oh
maybe you've known yeah this thought
bill is not so terrible
mr.
I actually think
I was even worse some moose ago it's so
bad
you
you
you know it's really
[Music]
can just you can just take everything
basically
I know he has to check me in I think
so he's not very quick Wow
I really shouldn't lose on time with
this I was super lucky I mean I guess I
didn't really I didn't really think too
hard it was more having fun with that
comment but still and I made a bed a
little bedroom here I also feel like I
should be fine here really I should be
fine
that'd be five looks wrong maybe this is
too simplistic to take it I mean I
should this is something that should be
preserved but maybe here is just it's
just bad I am c6 and then you go here
[Music]
yeah
and Bishop d4 is not good I don't think
it's the cause of my my trouble but
it is giving up on an advantage
c6 yeah I mean somewhere here
I think I had complete I know I was
really sitting what I did
huh why is that interesting and I
thought that wouldn't work due to c4 but
I have this
why am I not losing like this I saw
something like that
it turns out that this is not
totally clear no that was
beyond my powers and now I'm just lost
they're just lost
I don't sure if it's worth analyzing
relief or analyzing and looking looking
at
yeah here was a Bishop Miege that makes
no sense
I mean I had to play quickly but then as
sad as of course what I should do when
that could be a draw actually that could
be a draw
[Music]
to sing with a short amount of time
available
[Music]
you know Ned animals he just overstepped
the tournament it was still very bad
very bad at the end just lost I guess
it's just the last position okay I said
I hope you still enjoyed the video
mostly due to the hey stop at the very
beginning thanks a lot for watching